darkness rises congratulations everyone
you made it this is Star Wars week you
finally get your new Saga film so this
is gonna be my non-spoilery review so no
worries no spoilers for the last Jedi I
will talk about it as much as I can
without getting into super specifics but
the main takeaway is that this is the
movie that you were waiting for when you
heard that they were going to do a new
Star Wars franchise when Disney bought
out Lucasfilm make all the obi-wan memes
you want to this is the Star Wars movie
that you're looking for if you felt like
episode 7 was too much of a remake of
episode 4 this is the departure from
that it is the most different Star Wars
movie but at the same time the most Star
Wars movie that you've seen it blows the
mythology wide open it will get you
really excited for what Rian Johnson's
going to do with the new trilogy that
they just announced with completely new
characters because once you see what he
does with the brand new characters not
the ones that you've seen from episode 7
but the ones that he's just introduced
in how well they work in the story you
just get really jazzed up for what he's
going to be doing next inside the
universe but if you're just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything I'm also doing a
ticket giveaway that I'll explain at the
end of the video there will be plot
points things about the mythology that
they put forth that will be argued about
for years to come
even after we get episode 9 the key to
that is a lot of things that you've been
seeing in the trailers with Luke
Skywalker with Snoke with a lot of the
backstory that they teased out during
the movie so it's totally fascinating
obviously a lot of that they'll deal
with in the expanded material the movie
gives you as much information as you
need to understand the big twist of the
movie but beyond that you don't get this
big rap sheet about everything that
everybody's done their entire life so
everybody hoping to get all the answers
about Snoke about Rey's parents about
all the biggest questions you get clues
and information about that and enough to
put the pieces together like the theory
crafters will have so much fun with this
movie but it's not like they're gonna
tell you every exact little thing
getting into the actor performances I'd
say Daisy Ridley it
Adam driver probably gave the best
performances of the movie you can argue
about which you think is better after
you see it Mark Hamill was amazing as
methuselah Luke Skywalker he's been
telling that joke ever since they
started talking about the movie you may
have heard his comments about how he
completely disagreed with Rian Johnson's
take on the character when he first read
the script like how dare you do this to
Luke Skywalker this isn't what should be
happening he should be this other
different way Mark Hamill actually
developed a non canonical backstory for
Luke Skywalker before we meet him during
Episode seven and of course the movie
throws that out the window and it treats
his story the same way it treats Snoke
and the other characters too it gives
you all the information that you need
for this movie but it doesn't tell you
every last little thing I said the movie
blows the mythology the Jedi lore wide
open a lot of that has to do with Luke
Skywalker's character his arc that's
also why is going to be one of the most
argued about films in the fandom like
people just arguing about the way things
work the mechanics of everything in a
good way though not in a bad way
arguing over small Star Wars details is
one of the favorite pastimes of nerdom
so this will give you enough to go on
until we find out what's gonna happen
with the next saga with like episode 10
1112 but obviously we still have episode
9 so there's still gonna be a lot of new
stuff that we'll get but across the
board I feel like Brian Johnson did an
amazing job directing the actors all
their performances all the returning
people did much better jobs I loved some
of the pairings like you have the Rose
Finn stuff in the movie Finn was the
comedic relief of Episode seven that
continues with Episode eight it Rose
provides this nice foil for his
character so you can think of them as
like a buddy roadtrip comedy with in
this movie even though things get really
serious they do provide some comedic
relief if that's also kind of what they
use the porks for it's sort of like the
gremlins within the Star Wars movie you
may have seen some pictures from the
trailers them just being used in funny
ways
Chewbacca just swatting them off of the
dashboard of the Millennium Falcon for
those of you that are worried about the
level of pores in the film I feel like
there was an appropriate level not too
much not too little they're meant to
lighten the tone just a little bit
because we talked about the theme of red
in the movie how this is the heaviest
movie thematically in the franchise just
like em
fire was during the original trilogy the
whole idea of the resistance being the
spark that's going to light the fire is
going to burn down the first order is
also present in the Rey character
there's a spark inside her The Awakening
that we saw during Episode seven but she
has to choose what to do with that so
things go in a pretty dark direction
compared to what you're used to in other
Star Wars movies so there is some
appropriately used comedy to balance
that out so that's largely where the
Finn character comes in and along with
the porks so do not worry about porks
they're not a big plot point it's not
like they have some big third act reveal
they're not the Ewoks of the new trilogy
they're not that critical to the story
but speaking of critical to the story
Leia's character Carrie Fisher has an
amazing performance as you would expect
I feel like she did a good job during
Episode seven she has a lot more to do
and because things are so much darker in
this film obviously to do a great job of
referencing Han Solo in their
relationship their themes throughout the
film the music themes the music hues
that they bring back from the original
film's Star Wars rhymes like George
Lucas says but this is not a direct copy
of Empire the way that Episode seven
felt like a copy of Episode four so
don't worry about that but there are a
lot of familiar things from the original
trilogy from all three films as well as
the prequels there are even some brief
shoutouts to big prequel mythology
things so keep your ears peeled I don't
want to say what they are to give away
spoilers but we can talk about it later
this week the only complaints that I had
is that there are a couple of new
characters like I said the three new
ones are basically Admiral hold Oh DJ
Benicio Del Toro's character in Rose
Tico in via the virtue of the fact that
she's travelling with the Finn character
of those three characters Rose gets the
most screen time so I kind of feel like
they wasted Oscar Isaac just a little
bit even though they give him a lot more
to do in this film he still feels like
he doesn't get that much screen time in
Laura Dern is amazing and is probably
one of the most interesting new
characters that the franchise has
introduced they also kind of waste her a
little bit in the film too even though
she's a very important person so even
though it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie
Rey kylo ren's Snoke Luke Skywalker's
the force users of the film they get the
most screen time obviously that's not a
big surprise but at the same time there
are a couple really cool characters that
you just don't see quite enough of
there are so many new theories that the
movie is going to give birth to that I'm
really excited to talk about but we'll
have to wait a couple days just to give
people a chance to see the film but it's
gonna be a lot more fun to talk about
the franchise after this film than it
was after the force awakens then I think
people soured on a little bit with time
like people were really excited for Star
Wars to come back but then you watch the
force awakens a couple more times and
you start to realize why people
criticize it so much and I feel like
this film will still be well-received by
the time we get to Episode nine like oh
wow this is what we want when we say we
want some new Star Wars give us
something that feels like Star Wars but
isn't an exact copy of what we've seen
before I can't really talk about the
Jedi stuff the big battles of the film
without getting into super spoilers but
obviously the CG looks amazing they have
some crazy fights there is some amazing
Jedi stuff that they do in this and like
I said blow the mythology wide open you
see force abilities that you have not
seen before so rear ankang my favorite
Star Wars films from favorite to least
favorite and I included the holiday
special on this just for fun starting
with the top empire last Jedi New Hope
Return of the Jedi force awakens Revenge
of the Sith Attack of the Clones rogue
one then Phantom Menace and then at the
bottom I'll say holiday special because
it's fun to watch the holiday special
because it's so bad it's sort of a rite
of passage for the fandom so if you
yourself have a younger brother or a
younger sister that hasn't seen it or if
you're a parent and your child hasn't
seen it yet be sure to make them watch
that before the end of the year so they
can say they've done it at least once in
their life but all-in-all I feel like
this is going to be a great movie to
revisit I'll probably see it a couple
more times in the theater before the end
of the year if you have the chance to
see it in IMAX obviously it's worth the
extra money you don't have to see it in
3d that doesn't make it that much better
but if you really like 3d movies then
sure go for it but it is one of those
movies that's fun to re-watch and
obviously there's so much to unpack so
much that they do with the characters
that it takes a long time to process you
will want to see this multiple times but
I don't want to overstep and call it the
greatest movie to ever be made I mean
there are people that will probably say
that after this comes out people will
say it's the best Star Wars
movie ever putting it in context Empire
is still my favorite because at the time
it was brand new like it was forging new
ground and a lot of these later films
are still derivative even though they're
really amazing Brian Johnson made a
really amazing Star Wars film but it
still built on the bones of what came
before
so Empire still gets that top slot we'll
see what ends up happening with episode
9 it is gonna be really hard for episode
9 to be better than episode 8 and
suddenly you realize why Ryan Johnson
didn't want a direct episode 9 and
instead go off to this new trilogy with
completely different characters just so
that he could go out on such a high
watermark in the saga films so obviously
he's staying in the Star Wars universe
but he's not gonna do another saga film
for the foreseeable future but there is
a new round of that IMAX ticket giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a Star Wars related
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last video Jordan
Vasquez please private message me so I
can get your contact details without
answering your question I will say that
the movie helps eliminate a lot of the
bigger theories about the characters so
don't worry it's gonna get here in a
couple days my next Star Wars video will
probably be on Thursday night and
that'll be about the ending of the film
and some of the bigger twists then we'll
start talking about more spoilery stuff
over the weekend so just leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments but you can click here for that
last big trailer video and click here
for that brand new black panther trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight